yeah welcome to this video playing as I
walk out again I always have white and
they won three times already in there in
there Kings Indian against him so let's
see you can get another one no get a
modern modern defense hmm this good yeah
it leads to an only type of position
with one pair of knights exchanged but
okay he hasn't played c5 yet so he still
has ideas like c6 and set off see five
or six instead of leaf I so i probably
will play one of those c6 smile was my
suspicions yeah try to attack the center
and he sexy are both moose so at least
that was right in guessing the intention
question is some what to do now hmm
that's not easy
gather bishops not not really great on
on d3 but take with the sea party might
play c5 getting back into a benoni okay
let's let's play it play it simple if it
takes I can consider to take with the
night okay we're back in a bit unevenly
okay yeah well here I like the bishop on
d3 again so let's put it back it's a
it's not ideal but I want to our happen
a must prevent Bishop f5 here so what
now Queen d2 rookie won this structure
this benoni with it XD for it XD first
well known from the other back variation
of the Kings Indian usually in the other
back though there are some different
piece set up because there has been a
trade of the c8 bishop on a three so now
he still retains the bishop okay f4 I
would like to play but you can take III
and Bishop deform 95a some succumbing as
an idea so I probably need to move the
bishop again I don't want want him to to
take it okay so back again and then play
a flow
came so I much else if I want to make
some some progress here this is the way
to go
yeah I was just thinking about that man
takes an rookie three yeah
yeah this is the kind of tricks that
make this kind of position viable if he
goes Knight f7 instead it's just a very
one-sided game but why does eternally
better but this trick is working it is
working
while it's ugly okay I need to do that
but what else ya know is in excellent
shape so f for was was mistimed
unfortunately I mean it's maybe not the
end of the world I can exchange some
some pieces but while the position was
just better for white before no it's
it's just worse against the bishops yeah
gently let's exchange as long as
possible always some counter play also
against the King if he takes Queen takes
Queen yet these kind of ideas
hmm yeah 94 so in fact still an idea
attacking the the porn
bishop's III I can play Queen yet and
force a draw which I probably should do
this one intend increasing
huy 70 okay so am I getting too
optimistic here that I stood maybe can
try again to do something here we are
bill my nightie for the Sun is a move 95
maybe can take bit too but this looks
risky Yakima let's let's try that
activate the light okay he just believed
me and protected probably a brightly
some okay let's keep the poor now so how
to continue Queen night f2 may be
kicking the bishop I wonder what I would
like to do of course get the bishop to
g3 and and somehow get to d6 but I don't
see how to do that maybe I should go
Queenie to here intending g4 you form
yeah
gee for winning space no okay it's also
weakening but ok so we prevented that
specially after that I'm threatening g4
and I'm cutting cutting his own didn't
didn't consider that hmm Oh cram all of
the pin
hmm yeah yeah yeah
at the end Bishop c2 was a big issue ok
check I can't do that now it doesn't
even need to take here
time warning
can all the time it can take b3 and just
win easily but somehow it doesn't do it
I don't know why it's probably still
winning yeah it is still winning of
course but so I don't understand any any
move taking was just much easier check
yeah there should be five all right
white resigns yeah I got maybe after
after overlook nite chef why I got too
optimistic later he and I was out of the
worst can I got too optimistic I don't
know if I feel I shouldn't lose this
anymore but maybe I'm just too
optimistic probably ahem Queenie to
maybe night f2 on 93 yeah it's still
fighting against the two bishops so it's
it's ugly check can now just take on b3
and I resign this is much easier but so
I didn't do that but ok it's winning its
winning anyway we are 94 what a shot
yeah and I only saw it at the web just
briefly before you moved it but this was
very interesting I saw this rookie three
Bishop d4 idea I mentioned it before but
the thing is I just need to prepare
and and white us in good shape here the
typical kind of position where white is
somewhat better against a Bernoulli
structure move like a five or just even
a king move you can consider but ok King
King on the edge file on desk on the
screen edge for coming maybe also i can
also consider the show page six i must
drop all the way back to f1's also
possible energy form we could move yeah
maybe maybe this one and then f4 yeah I
like that actually this should be ok
getting rid of this and then player for
I still have this advantage in space
this is why why this better like it's
just a bit cramped it's not losing or
something but it's just a good
comfortable position for white but here
this is really a move to remember thanks
for watching